I'm noticing that Jerry Bruckheimer and
Disney have this talent of taking ideas
that sound completely ridiculous and
half-baked and somehow make them
surprisingly entertaining first we had
Pirates of the Caribbean now we have
national treasure the story to get a lot
of this apparently our founding fathers
weren't just trying to make this nation
a free nation but they were also hiding
this ancient treasure that's right
a giant treasure that they believed
shouldn't belong to any one man so they
left Clues in all their giant landmarks
and of course only one crazy treasure
hunter can actually locate it
he's play fittingly enough by Nicolas
Cage who tries to tell everybody that
there's a treasure map on the back of
the Declaration of Independence and big
shock
they don't believe it but he's being
chased by a villain played by Sean Bean
surprisingly doesn't die in this movie
god I think that's a first who's trying
to collect the treasure for himself La
Cage is just doing it to restore his
family name along the way there's car
chases shootouts a romance a comedic
side character all that good stuff so
I'm not gonna lie I was really ready to
hate this film especially from watching
the opening I was laughing out loud and
how absolutely absurd this all sounded
but as the movie went on you kind of
realized it's meant to be absurd but not
to that noxious point where it's always
winking to the camera it still takes it
really seriously and that's where a lot
of comedy comes from it actually reminds
me a lot of the new show Sleepy Hollow
yeah that idiotic set up when the
Headless Horseman has a machine gun but
you find yourself actually enjoying it
because they do take their stupidity so
seriously and at the center of it is
Nicolas Cage and he is the reason this
film works I think with any other actor
this film would have died nobody could
find that exact balance of kind of kooky
but kinda serious at the same time as
him the way he talks about these
ridiculous ideas he knows it sounds
insane but he's not really rolling his
eyes he's sort of just stating the facts
and saying will you help me or not but
he's not a stick-in-the-mud either he's
still a little kooky
that's very tough to pull off and still
have people want to follow you but he
does a really good job I also like the
fact that they really do spend time
trying to figure out how to find the
treasure they sit down they talk they
discuss ideas they talk about codes you
actually do find yourself getting really
wound up in it if anything the most
boring parts are the action scenes
they're just sort of standard and you
see them a million times but it's like
the movie knows they're kind of standard
so it doesn't spend that much time with
it the main focus is on the mysteries
and the puzzles and trying to find the
treasure and it's strangely really fun
and you get into it I'd say that if you
tell yourself there's no way you're
gonna like this idea then it's gonna be
exactly that an idea you're not gonna
like but kind of like with the Herbie
movies if you have even the slightest
interest or the slightest wiggle room my
guess is this movie might win you over
and I also like the fact that you really
forget it's a Disney film the way they
talk the way they act you don't
associate it with that typical kind of
Disney way it just feels like a
straight-up action flick that's
enjoyable and kind of goofy but not in a
Disney way in its own sort of unique way
even the climax is not this big
overblown climax it's actually a very
reasonable smart ending so yeah I
surprisingly recommend it if you have a
good sense of humor or just looking for
a bit of fun and not to take anything
too seriously but not have your
intelligence insulted either and this is
a good rent it's got just the right
amount of fun the right amount of
goofiness and the right amount of action
go ahead and discover it for yourself
you